a una nueva jornada de ira en el
ultramar francés en guadalupe el sábado
se repitieron las manifestaciones
mientras en las noches hombres armados
disparan contra policías y manifestantes
y esto es martinica el sábado amaneció
con una estación de servicio y una
oficina de correos calcinadas la crisis
social no cesa estamos reclamando
nuestros derechos aquí en martinica
esperaba que rompieran que robaran pero
no 15 enviar en una gasolinera te das
cuenta una estación es una bomba pero la
presión ha surtido efecto y la
vacunación obligatoria para personal de
salud y bomberos se ha [__] hasta
el 31 de diciembre
ahora las demandas van mucho más allá
desnudando otras grietas en el pacto
social
el ministro de ultramar sebastián de
cognis anunció el viernes el inicio de
negociaciones para aumentar la autonomía
ciudadanos de guadalupe sienten que la
medida de la vacunación vino impuesta
desde francia nosotros los ciudadanos e
incluso los representantes elegidos no
tenemos la sartén por el mango aquí en
guadalupe en cuanto a la toma de
decisiones
el ministro también anunció la creación
de mil puestos de trabajo subvencionados
para jóvenes en guadalupe una medida que
busca recuperar la paz social en una
región de francia donde el 34.5 por
ciento de la población vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza